and if you want to be a professional
writer then i think it's a great balance
to look at anything you write as a
possible sample versus i have to sell it
are there any other best practices
that'll help someone get their start i
think those
first few of
knowing who you are as a writer
what you like to write
what your end goal is
um
and then
honing in on that
to me and then obviously figuring out
the business figuring out the business
is the hardest part because just like
there's no formal education on
screenwriting unless you're in film
school there's no formal education on
the business like you can even go to
film school and not learn the business
right that part's going to be more trial
and error
but as far as those other things those
are kind of the best practices get out
there try and try again you know in the
beginning stages
write all kinds of stuff and see what
you enjoy um something that i ask my
students is what do you like to watch
what do you like to write because a lot
of the times those two things don't add
up
and so if you know that going forward i
mean from from the beginning then now
you can make sure that you're uh your
samples your materials actually add up
to what you want to do because if you're
out in the world saying oh yeah i love
watching one-hour dramas but you're
writing half-hour comedies right
then are you saying that you want to
work in dramas but for whatever reason
you've been writing comedies or do you
actually want to write in comedies and
so now you know i should be reading
those comedy scripts instead of those
one-hour drama scripts even though i
like watching those one-hour drama
scripts so really just trying to figure
out who you are as a writer
what your end goal is so that you can
start working your way there and then
once you're in a little more you can
start concerning yourself with getting
representatives and getting all that
other kind of stuff but it really just
starts with the craft and also
understanding that everybody out there
is just trying no one has the answer
right everybody's um journey into this
hollywood machine is different if you
decide to go independent it's going to
be different because you're doing it on
your own so just having the confidence
to say if i've decided that i'm going to
sign up for this then i'm just going to
do it and i'm just going to roll with
the punches how they come
are there any false beliefs that new
writers have that sometimes just drive
you crazy hmm false beliefs
i think one of the biggest ones is that
they think it'll happen overnight you
know they think well i have this idea
and it really has to be on tv by next
year because what's happening right now
you know is is uh is so important that
this story has to be told and i can tell
them i agree with you
the industry just doesn't work that way
all right it just takes time so i think
that's one of the biggest ones is just
not realizing how much time it takes to
do things um
i'm trying to think are there any other
false beliefs that people have
i think that's the biggest one
yeah okay so i mean let's suppose let's
say i watched um
startup or queen's gambit or one of
these excellent series and i want to do
i have this great idea that it's going
to be very similar
is that its own mistake because it's
already been done and it's already been
done so well why try to not necessarily
not necessarily in my opinion there are
no new ideas
uh especially now hollywood is big on
reboots and remakes right so they're big
on established ip period
so if it's already been done the
question is what are you going to do
that makes it unique what's going to
make it different you make it different
first of all because your experience in
this world is different so if you decide
to tell a story about a kid who doesn't
know who his parents are and lives uh
with his
uncle who are emotionally abusive it
doesn't mean that it turns into harry
potter right but it's still got the same
premise that this child is looking for
identity right so it's okay if you've
seen it
you just have to figure out what unique
thing you're bringing to the table the
other thing is trying to follow the
trends of hollywood some people are into
trends some people want to write what
they are already seeing on television
because they think that's what's being
purchased i'm here to tell you if you're
watching it the trend has passed
right
in hollywood the trends passed every few
months right so whatever that production
company studio network or streamer was
looking for in january they're not
looking for that same thing by june so
if right now you're seeing vampires on
every network and you're working on a
vampire pilot right now in your house
doesn't mean don't write it but it does
mean that by the time you're able to
pitch it to someone we're not into
vampires anymore we've moved on so i
tell people you know you have to decide
if you're going to follow the trends or
not that can be a good thing for you if
you're already a professional writer and
you're already in the game therefore you
hear about the trend before the trend
starts so that yes you want to be
writing the thing that you know that
they're looking for because all of those
studios et cetera have mandates and so
they can say at whatever part of the
year we're looking for vampire stories
where you're ahead of the game go write
a vampire story but if you are just
starting out and you're seeing all the
vampire stories on tv or on the big
screen then that trend has already
passed so then now it comes to maybe i
should just write what i'm interested in
period and when it becomes something
people want to read great or like i've
said before
sometimes it's not about selling
something and it's about having it as a
sample to show how great of a writer you
are because if you can write vampires
i'm going to assume you can write ghost
i'm going to assume you can write
werewolves i'm going to assume that you
can write in this science fiction
fantasy you know world or maybe horror
whatever it is uh whatever kind of story
it was so you can still use that as a
sample to get you into the next thing it
may not get purchased and if you want to
be a professional writer
then i think it's a great balance to
look at anything you write as a possible
sample versus i have to sell it
because you don't have control over what
happens on the other side unless you're
doing it independently so if you write
some things i have to sell this then now
you're setting yourself up for
disappointment if you don't versus
saying i'm writing a fantastic sample
and i'm going to show this to someone
and those people might like it and they
might decide they want to buy it now
when right now you have a win um but
yeah i would say just
focus on writing what you like to write
um that's what makes it fun if it's not
gonna be fun we could all be doing
something else right we can all be uh
we're we took on this creative job
because it's supposed to be fun if it's
not going to be fun then we could be
doing whatever job someone else tried to
push us into
what if i say well i'm going to
resurrect an old show like the office
but we're going to all be on zoom
or or facebook live or google chat and
we're gonna just it's gonna be so cool
and it'll be the same office politics
but now we're all virtual and our bosses
are spying on us at home yeah so it'll
be really cool and it's been a few years
since the show was on so i can resurrect
it right maybe
right if someone out there is interested
in it if someone out there is looking
for something like it um like i said
before hollywood is kind of interested
in established ip at this point and not
to say that you would then have to get
in touch with the people who made the
office and blah blah blah have to be
different enough because if it's the
same thing then now you're infringing on
their copyright
right so you're not necessarily making
the office unless you are right there
are a lot of reboots that are being made
right now and they're making uh bel air
which is a reboot of the fresh prince of
bel air right with an entirely different
group of people but that means that they
went through the proper channels to make
sure that there's no infringement etc
etc so they can do that so instead of
saying you're making the office make
something that is new and original and
say that it's like the office right
unless of course you have the permission
to be making the office and doing it you
know doing something different with it
but you know again like i said there in
my opinion there aren't any new ideas
i've had people pitch me the same idea
in three different states from three
different people and one of those first
people wasn't even a writer
and i was just like wow this is crazy
how we're all living in the same world
right now so we're all getting the same
information and that's
making a lot of us create the same ideas
if that makes sense um so if there was
something about the office that you
enjoyed ask yourself
what was it about the office that i
enjoyed
maybe that's the thing that you take
and turn into your own thing because the
office doesn't own office politics right
if any of us have ever worked in a
corporate space then we know office
politics right so the people who made
the office don't own that space what
they did to make it different was the
way they filmed it the mockumentary
style etc etc but other than that it's
all the same stuff that we'd see in any
other kind of office right um so asking
yourself what is it that i liked from
that and then how can i put that into
this idea that i have that's about zoom
or about whatever it is so that it i'm
turning it on its head so that there's
something unique about it and now i can
utilize the office as proof that this
may work but i'm not necessarily selling
you the office uh so maybe like pam she
was yeah okay so let's say pam's
character type let's say she was the
go-to gal and she knew where all the
staples were and you know and everybody
kind of needed her all at once so i'm
going to make a series sort of like
based on her life but it's she's going
to be at home but it's not really taking
the office's ip it's just a kind of a
caricature of mm-hmm
exactly someone like pam if you decide
to make it pam then now you're
infringing right but if you do something
like pam because again pam exists
because that person exists in all
offices there's always somebody who
knows where everything is you know that
maybe that's the coordinator maybe it's
um uh the admin uh the uh
the ceo's a
administrative assistant or whoever it
is but somebody in that office everybody
knows i'm gonna go ask her she's gonna
be able to get it to me and ask him he's
gonna be able to get it so that's not a
new idea
right so being able to say well that's
what i thought was interesting this
particular character knowing everything
about the office right so then you have
to then of course build your story from
there because that's a character that's
not enough to get you a story or a pilot
or a series but understanding that
that's the thing that you're pulling
from then that can work for you
so pam's a remote worker but she has
another job on the side that her boss
doesn't know about and she's doing it on
company time and it's a little bit more
nefarious
and so she's gotta make sure that she's
on point for the office
but then she's doing i don't know she's
taking adult surveys or she's doing
something that's like it's not horrible
but it's like whoa you know pam what are
you doing right right right so the
balance of that will then be what the
series is about and then figuring out
what the stakes are that she is doing
that like does she has she signed some
kind of clause in her everyday job that
says that she shouldn't be or can't be
doing this thing so that if they find
out that she's doing this thing then
this thing is in jeopardy
right so you have to ask yourself you
know what is the story right someone
doing those two things okay cool but
what do they have to do with each other
how do they you know crash into each
other to cause a problem like does she
have a problem trying to balance the two
you know or what does it become so you
still have to then build out the entire
story around pam or you know the
pam-like character to see what it's
gonna become
you